okay
okay take three welcome back I gotta hug
you one more time is that what you
wanted yeah it is I actually hope the
mic fails again so we could do that
it's great uh to have you back great
again
just so they kept cutting out and uh we
talked about so I asked you how you'd
like to go outside you said you want to
marry me and get you pregnant
I didn't I don't think I said that you
definitely said that I don't remember
saying that but it's just TV so it's
different but I do want to have um an
actual conversation and take you out for
a national date
um you've clearly won
so yeah we were talking about um the jab
and how you can't trust somebody
I'm just taking it because they can
they're gonna trust the government again
yeah it's hard to be with a man who has
had it because you know if you if they
fell for that what else are they gonna
fall for in the future like with the new
outdoor job that are they gonna fall for
that and believe that it's kind of
changed as well like you have to be
careful with who you
um exactly because you have to have the
same mindset otherwise
you know you hear stories of people not
wanting to
um jab their kids and then the partner
grows and does it behind their back
which is like that's probably the worst
thing that's a divorceable offense 100 I
think it's a crime it should be a crime
I haven't heard any stories about that
but yeah I mean I would say it's clearly
the next pandemic they're going to go
and track a carbon footprint they're
going to tell us how much we can go
outside how much we can use gas how much
we could use our air conditioning and
that's kind of way that they're going to
quarantine us so another Fair campaign
Santa is a sign up all the societal
you're using all the same looking yeah
they control everybody with fear and
they brainwash a lot of people into
and I've seen it with a lot of the girls
that we've been on dates that I've been
on days with today they're just like
they're clubbing all the time and
they're they're not really focused on
the future and I like that you have a
clear plan for your future and what you
want
um I was really surprised that you said
you want seven kids that's like a
maybe more you think you can handle it
yeah how old are you 22. oh yeah you can
handle it you gotta say soon though
and I wouldn't be opposed to it right
now I'm not doing anything like
that like I'm not partying or anything
I've never really had that in me so why
not start now
some of the better I agree I always
wanted to be a young father
but yeah this was um
I don't really find often that I click
with somebody this quickly yeah
and you said earlier when it might cut
out that there's even a dating app for
unjabbed people
you haven't used it though right I
haven't used it but I know it's there
I just like in person
um meetings more I feel like it's more
natural
yeah I think it's extremely important I
don't think if you meet somebody on an
app or something it's like if Bill
gateshead Mark Zuckerberg orchestrated
it
it's strange
but yeah you won and this is our third
time having this conversation so we're
having the force a little bit we're
having to repeat things but it still
feels
natural
can I have your your contact information
did that before no Snapchat though no I
don't have to I'm a grown man
it's nice to hear
kind of not
usually nowadays
[Music]
we can cut that right we're good I won
I won she won but I won all right we're
good
I want to give you a prize or something
a price yeah I don't think I could smell
it anymore
yeah you couldn't
okay okay
well can you see a way she would
uh it's pretty obvious I mean
we I think we connect well to help out I
hope we do some of them are worse
um I want to continue talking to you I
don't feel like I'm entertaining right
now am I making you nervous no okay
just everything about you
there's one I'm actually sitting here
right now
so let's let's get some food
steak steak yeah okay thanks
are you serious sometimes in the morning
like with milk and honey I'm about
eggnog
is
okay yeah cool
we I won we win
we win
[Music]